Hello. This is 6 Minute English
from BBC Learning English. I’m Neil.
And I’m Beth. There are some well-known
English expressions that make a link
between seeing and eating. ‘Your eyes
are bigger than your belly’ means you
have taken more food than you can
eat; and the saying you eat with
your eyes first means that food seems more
desirable when it looks good on the plate.
But seeing isn’t the only sense involved in
tasting food - in fact, it may not even be
the most important. First, you see your favourite
bacon sandwich, then comes its delicious smell,
quickly followed by the crunchy feel
and salty taste as you take a bite.
Now scientists are learning more about the
power of another of our senses – sound – and
how it affects our sense of taste. ‘Sonic seasoning’
is the idea that when you hear certain sounds or
music, they can enhance one flavour or another
in the food you’re eating. In this programme
we'll be eating with our ears as we investigate
the link between sound and our tastebuds. And,
as usual, we'll be learning some
useful new vocabulary as well.
But first I have a question for you, Beth.
The idea that sounds influence taste might
seem strange, but the food-processing companies
that produce some of our most familiar food and
drinks have long known that sound equal sales.
In the UK, for example, the chocolate company,
Cadbury, hired the London Contemporary Orchestra
to perform classical music tunes symbolising each
flavour of their Dairy Milk chocolates. So,
which background sound did whisky-makers,
Singletons, used to advertise
their scotch whisky? Was it:
a) jazz music?
b) bagpipes playing? or,
c) birds tweeting?
I’ll guess they used some smooth jazz music.
OK, Beth. I'll reveal the answer later in
the programme. Charles Spence is professor of
experimental psychology at Oxford University.
After years studying how our brains process
information, he believes sound plays a much bigger
role in how we taste our food than we think,
something he explained to Mike Johnson, presenter
of BBC World Service programme, The Food Chain:
In general how big a contribution do you think
these sounds, and sound generally, actually makes
to how we perceive food compared to the more
obvious senses, of course, of sight and smell?
So I think it's much more important than
we realise, and that can start from before
we’ve put anything into our mouth - it can be this
sound of the sizzle of the steak on the hot plate,
it can be the gurgle and the sizzle and
the steam of the coffee machine… those are
all cues that set up expectations
about what we're about to taste.
Professor Spence uses onomatopoeia to describe
some sounds. Onomatopoeia is when a word sounds
like what it means, words like 'buzz', ‘zoom’ and
‘whack’. He uses the word sizzle for the hissing
sound made by frying meat, and describes a
coffee machine using the word gurgle - the
low pleasant sound liquids make when flowing
quickly through a narrow space. Professor Spence
thinks that hearing these sounds while eating
psychologically intensifies the flavour of food.
But it's not just psychologists… the food industry
has also discovered the selling power of sound.
Nowadays restaurants everywhere are carefully
selecting the music they play on their dining-room
playlists. Reporter, Gianna Palmer, visited New
York restaurant, Smashburger, where every song is
specially chosen by professional music pickers.
Here she interviews one of them, Amy Frishkey,
head of music design company, Mood Media, for
BBC World Service programme, The Food Chain:
Music just kind of has the ability to put
you in a different space and a lot of times,
then your mood could lead to an
impulse buy that you didn't plan on…
You're having such a good time
eating out, ‘oh, I'll get dessert!’
Yeah right… I'm really enjoying the music,
I think I'll linger here a bit longer.
Choosing the right dining-room music
not only makes food taste better,
it puts people in a good mood - something
which might lead to an impulse buy – suddenly
buying something you had not planned
to because you want it when you see it.
What’s more, a good restaurant
atmosphere encourages customers
to linger – to stay longer than necessary
because they’re having a good time. Of course,
the longer customers linger and the more they buy
on impulse, the more money a restaurant makes.
I think it's time you revealed
the answer to your question,
Neil. You asked me which background
sound drinks company, Singletons,
used to advertise their whisky. I guessed
it was jazz music… so was I right?
That was… the wrong answer I'm afraid, Beth.
In fact, Singletons used the sound of birds
tweeting to sell their whisky - probably
a better idea than using bagpipes! OK,
let's recap the vocabulary we've
learned from this programme on sonic
seasoning starting with the English
saying, you eat with your eyes first,
an idiom meaning that when food is
visually appealing, it's more appetizing.
Onomatopoeia is when words sound like what they
mean, for example ‘boom’, ‘whack’ and ‘moo’.
Other examples of onomatopoeia are sizzle
- a hissing sound, and gurgle – the low
pleasant sound a liquid makes when it
flows quickly through a narrow space.
An impulse buy is suddenly buying something that
you had not planned to because
you want it when you see it.
And finally the verb to linger means to stay
somewhere longer than necessary because you’re
enjoying yourself. Once again our six
minutes are up. Join us next time for
more trending topics and useful vocabulary
here at Six Minute English. Goodbye everyone!
Bye!